who are the winners and losers of this
tax break if it does come to pass well
the winners are the same companies that
are winning now in the u.s tax system
they're ones that are able to shift
income outside the u.s and get low tax
rates around the world i think tech
companies think pharmaceutical companies
anyone who's really earning money from
patents or other intellectual property
richard this is interesting because this
idea this patent box the innovation box
this idea seems to be pleasing to both
sides of the aisle on capitol hill you
don't find that a lot right the two key
senators who are working on this are
chuck schumer of new york and rob
portman of ohio who often don't
necessarily agree on on tax policy and
so what's going on here is democrats see
this as a way to promote innovation to
try and attract and keep jobs in the us
to make the u.s an attractive place to
headquarter a company and republicans
see it as a way to provide a tax break
and do some of the same things and so
there's a chance now tax reform is
always
just down the road and never quite here
and so that's there's any number of
details and issues that would have to
get worked out so in theory it could be
pleasing to both sides i wonder though
for individuals who want to stop paying
taxes or reduce their tax obligations
usually for expats living abroad it's a
long and windy road to get out of those
obligations you've got to renounce your
citizenship you've got to pay what a 2
350 fee you have to pay an exit tax on
all your assets from your homes your
retirement savings to artwork jewelry
stocks it might seem easier for
companies to relinquish their u.s tax
obligations but there's plenty of red
tape there too as well right yeah these
inversion deals that we've seen over the
past year milan and medtronic and other
companies like that that have moved
abroad those aren't necessarily easy
they spend a lot of money on lawyers and
fees and everything trying to get out
but even beyond that what companies are
able to do is move their assets abroad
and and then earn the income overseas so
a lot what a lot of companies have been
able to do is take their patents their
trademarks their formulas put them in
low-tax countries and then say all the
income is earned there that's under
pressure around the world now and
richard just quickly this is it would be
a new way for companies at least to keep
their intellectual property here right
it's definitely incentive for companies
to bring some of those assets that
they've put overseas to bring them back
and develop new ones here that's the
idea at the same time the potential
problem is for companies that don't have
a lot of tax breaks now that are paying
high rates retailers necessarily that's
who might get hurt from this